so if New York is the city that never
sleeps does that make awesome the city
that ever dies so I took a lot longer to
get caught up and current and active
again with Gotham then I had planned I
had set a while back I was gonna start
doing episode I have so reviews and this
is me basically trying to catch up and
do that now obviously I am NOT gonna do
individual episode reviews for the first
five episodes of the season so let me
sort of sum up my feelings really
quickly and then get into the latest
episode to air episode 6 which was Hog
Day Afternoon so coming into season 4 I
enjoyed season 3 quarrel I mean I just I
love the show I think the show was
fantastic I really liked where things
started out I like the position penguin
is in I like the whole idea and the
concept of the licenses I love the way
they were introduced Victor's been
getting a lot of really nice highlights
throughout the season so I'm digging all
of that the early stuff was scarecrow
was pretty cool I thought that was neat
it was nice to see him come back after
you know he we hadn't seen Jonathan
crane since season 1 I don't think so
that was only I would liked that the
solomon grundy stuff is I'm still making
up my mind just because he is I mean the
the characters a bit goofy and I I
almost kind of wish he just he didn't
talk like if it was just
grunting and repeating that nursery
rhyme because there's something about
the me Tarzan you Jane way of speaking
that makes it a little bit tough to to
by that said that the actor you know who
had been playing butch and I thought was
great as butch he does sell the
physicality and the size and the
imposing 'no solomon grundy pretty well
so that's working i'm finding the stuff
with the IDI to be interesting i kind of
need to see where it's gonna go but i
think that's an interesting sort of
curveball to throw him as a character
that he's he's head is scrambled he is
not as smart as he once was and there's
a part of me that wonders that's not
almost make him more dangerous the fact
that he
doesn't really know what he's doing
anymore and I'll be interested to see
that how that pans out Lee coming back
that's all so let me see what's going on
her introduction into things that worked
pretty well for me
brie and Sophia Falcone I'm nitpicky on
that cuz if they were gonna have Sophia
Falcone as a character I really would
have preferred that they had physically
someone who matched Sophia Falcone from
the comics who is huge like she's this
huge wall of a woman
and yeah they just went for a generic
looking thing I figured the reason they
did that is because they had Jim hook up
with her and I guess they probably
weren't gonna have him hook up with
someone bigger than him and I think
that's a shame now I think Gotham of any
show on television this show that could
have gotten away with that but anyway so
there's that bit if there's a weakness
to the season so far
it's it's the whole racial goofus stuff
that hasn't really worked for me and and
I could ramble on that for a while but
let me get through it so I can get to
the the actual current episode so I
think the they found the one area of the
Batman mythos mythology that I think
doesn't actually work when you stick it
into the world that they built for
Gotham and that is flat-out magic now
we've had plenty of iffy stuff you know
all the hypnosis stuff I mean and Alice
practically has magic blood but the
thing is pretty much everything is
rooted in some degree of I don't want to
say truth but some sort of science basis
you know we've had people coming back
from the dead but it's through you know
Frankenstein technology I mean you know
it's mad doctors and it's scientists and
you know hypnosis has a basis in fact
and they just took it to an extreme so
when this guy shows up claiming to be
thousands of years old with a dagger and
he actually God they actually said the
word prophecy I kind of checked out
mentally that doesn't that doesn't feel
right it doesn't feel like Gotham and
I'm right now I'm if he
on Barbara having been brought back now
I love Barbara I I hated her first
season loved her season 2 and season 3
especially she has been phenomenal but I
also felt like that was a good point to
close her out when she died last season
and I said that before I think and
bringing her back she also seems less
crazy which makes her less fun so I kind
of want to see that back get back on its
it's streak I think if the racial Google
thing is gonna have any interesting
impact it might be the impact it has on
Bruce and we'll see how that plays out
but this latest episode for my tastes
and why I tune into Gotham is getting
these back on track and that is with the
introduction of Professor Pig and they I
don't know why I hadn't thought they
would you know lean on the the pig cop
as you know as a slang for cop angle and
have him going after corrupt cops which
means he actually really admires Jim
Gordon because he is more or less the
incorruptible cop on the force so that
is interesting I just think the vibe of
Professor Pig you know because he's this
weird kind of creepy
killer with an odd methodology and that
that's Gotham that's the show I love so
I feel like this episode is giving
things kind of back on track in a way
after you know again the racial drool
stuff just it felt off it felt like you
belong in a different version of Batman
and of this world than this one has been
giving us so yeah I mean that's that's
kind of it I this ended up being a lot
of a summary of my thoughts on the
season at this point and only a little
bit about the about the new episode
Gordon still working for me i Bullock I
don't know I think it was odd that they
tried to milk a lot of emotion out of
the reveal that Bullock was taking money
from penguin I mean that's that's
disappointing but at the same time we
know
he was a dirty cop in the past and under
the circumstances that he's in it didn't
seem like that huge leap it's it's one
of those things that I think if they had
just played up if Jim had had basically
I'm not mad I'm just disappointed kind
of parenting moment with Harvey I think
that would have rang more true than you
know the more the hello you've been
taking money from penguin you know more
sort of way that they went for it I
think they just came at that revelation
from maybe not the best angle
penguins work I mean penguin always
works for me I am nervous about the
Sophia Falcone thing if only because it
feels like it's potentially hitting too
many of the same notes as what happened
with Edie last season and that I think
that's one of the dangers with this
interpretation of the penguin is that
he's he is various he's effective but
he's incredibly driven by his emotions
which makes him fairly easy to
manipulate for people who can get in his
head just well enough to understand what
are gonna what things are gonna push his
buttons so the the result of that is
work I kind of feel like right now this
is potentially retreading some similar
ground with him you know developing some
emotion kind of emotional connection
with the person or believing that he is
cuz I'm sure she's playing him but
obviously this it's it's a little
different because he's more guarded
because of what happened with it but
again it just it it feels just at a
basic fundamental level a bit like a
retread and I really loved all the stuff
between Edie and penguin in the last
season so we'll see I feel like this
show is has has gotten maybe a bit
character heavy and I think it's
reluctance to kill characters and let
them stay dead might be starting to bite
it in the butt a little bit because that
as I'm talking about all this I'm
realizing how
little we've seen of some of the
characters or how long it's been since
we last saw them I think three episodes
now since we saw IV take the stuff that
she took so we still don't know what
that did to her and that seems like an
oddly long period of time after having
set that up too for us to get a payoff
on that we haven't seen a lot whole lot
of Selina you know then it it seems like
this is a show that kind of could use a
little bit of a colleague it could use a
red wedding to thin the ranks a little
bit but you know nobody stays dead in
Gotham which Harvey actually comments on
which I love I am really curious since I
mentioned ivy I am really curious to see
how they're gonna visually have that
look I'm surprisingly I'm kind of liking
ivy I like that they created a character
who that aging her up basically gave her
a command over people's attention that
she doesn't really know how to use fully
properly and she's not mature enough to
to really be in that body and it's and
it's in a way that is believable to me
because she's she's flaky in the way
that somebody who's the age she should
be would be flaky so I find all that
interesting and I'll be curious to see
how that pays out on this really wasn't
specific to this episode I'm gonna have
to title this thing just overview of
season 4 episodes 1 through 6 because
that's kind of what it was so yeah again
coming back strong most of the core cast
is doing good Alfred's had some really
good highlight moments Bruce's working
for me scarecrow was good
Rachele ghoul didn't care for he
appeared to die but that seemed like an
odd least short period in which to kill
off a not only a character from the
comics who's that big but who was
theoretically behind the court of owls
who had been behind Hugo Strange so like
this is the guy behind the guy
who were behind the guy and I don't know
it seems short-lived so I'm sure he's
gonna come back somehow but Professor
Pig that on digging that that feels more
like where Gotham should be you know
ground level dirty messed up crime as
opposed to you know global international
jet-setting immortal guy I guess
so those are my rambling sleep-deprived
spots on Gotham
season four so far are you watching it
if you're watching this video I assume
you are what are your thoughts I know
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher
I'm also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast that's available on the
fire and water podcast network Fire and
Water podcast calm and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]